Alexandria Ocasio Cortez who studied
economics in college and writes economic
policy in Congress can't name the most
prominent economists of the 20th century
MSNBC's Katy tur doesn't know how
senators get elected and Joe Biden wants
to ban guns that don't exist the problem
isn't that our alleged elites are
ignorant it's that they know so much
that isn't so we examine the root of
their confusion then Joe Biden collapses
in the polls bloomberg surges and Snoop
Doggy dog gets the media to expose
themselves all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]
oh we've got so much to get to
AOC is out here educating all of us
about economists that don't exist we
have to wonder how our elites got so
profoundly ignorant I think I have the
answer actually we will all be less
ignorant when we figure that one out but
first I've got to thank our friends over
at AB sleep you know me I like to get at
least 18 19 hours of sleep at night
that's not always possible but there is
a way if you are having trouble sleeping
to get a few more Z's at night and that
is M sleep a wearable solution that fits
over the forehead and gently and
precisely cools the forehead to reduce
those racing thoughts and allow people
who suffer from sleeplessness to drift
more comfortably into a deeper more
restorative sleep if you suffer from
insomnia if you have trouble sleeping a
lot of people my family have trouble
sleeping one of the reasons for that is
your mind is just always racing that the
minds normal way of dealing with stress
and challenges is to just be on guard to
be really tense to be vigilant in the
middle of the night that stops you from
getting a restful night's sleep that's
where comes in AB is clinically
validated and four out of five users
report falling asleep faster and
improving overall sleep quality it's
also very good if you have a headache
the same same kind of thing going on but
if you've got those racing thoughts AB
is the way to cool your mind down and
get that sleep you need have the energy
to do things you love again by getting
the sleep you need herbs natural
solution has no morning side effects and
allows you to get back to your peak
performance our listeners can try AB
risk-free for 60 nights to confirm it's
the solution you've been looking for at
Tri EV comm slash Knolls
that's t ry e BB dot-com slash Noel's
try AB comm slash Noel's canna wles
order today get the sleep you need and
deserve
sometimes when I'm watching our elites
on air I I start to be lulled into sleep
because of how mind-numbing it is
nowhere is this clearer than with AOC so
you know AOC is always posting these
videos on various social media platforms
just rambling about whatever thought
to endure head and comes at her mouth
without very little filter in the middle
she did this the other day to talk about
one of her favorite economists and she
was I think attempting to cite one of
the most famous economists of the 20th
century unfortunately she named an
economist who doesn't exist funny you
asked this because I was just reading
today about how Milton Keynes a famous
economist back in the day predicted that
by 2030 US GDP would grow six to eight
times what it is which would allow for
everyday people to work 15 hours a week
milton keynes milton keynes is not an
economist Milton Keynes as far as I know
is not a person who has ever existed
what I think she's trying to refer to is
the economist John Maynard Keynes and
she's confusing John Maynard Keynes who
she says he was a very big economist
back in the day she doesn't even know
when he lived and worked he was an
economist who was born at the end of the
19th century and lived until the mid
20th century very famous liberal
left-wing economist she's confusing John
Maynard Keynes with Milton Friedman
who's the very famous right-wing
economists you know they're all these
videos of Milton Friedman from the 1970s
and 1960s giving lectures on economics
he was very influential during the
Reagan administration very influential
for the conservative movement she's
confusing to economists who are pretty
much on the opposite end of economics in
the 20th century and even more so she's
not even pronouncing the one guy's name
correctly John Maynard Keynes she's
calling him Keynes like the steak house
in New York I don't really blame her for
not knowing who John Maynard Keynes was
I mean she was an economics major in
college and now she's writing economics
policy in Congress so it would be nice
if she had even a passing familiarity
with who the guy was but my problem is
not that she hasn't read the the total
work of of Keynes or that she hasn't
read to all the work of Milton Friedman
or that she's ignorant the ignorance
isn't even my problem my problem is the
lack of curiosity
my problem is the pomposity of just
pontificating of just running her mouth
about things that she doesn't know
anything about it's this lack of
awareness that she is profoundly
ignorant I think if you look at her
effect if you look at the way she speaks
she presents herself as very well
educated very intelligent she knows so
much more than everybody else and yet
she doesn't she doesn't know what she's
talking about and this is true of so
many of our so-called elites in politics
in the media all around us you know
people just throw around terms that they
think make them sound smart one of them
being Keynesian Keynesian refers to
economic policies that follow the work
of John Maynard Keynes which is the guy
that she's erroneously referring to as
Milton or yeah Milton Keynes you hear
this term Keynesian you'll hear this
term Rousseau Ian right people always
refer to Rousseau Ian if they want to
sound very highfalutin and fancy to
refer to the works of jean-jacques
Rousseau that nobody's ever read
Rousseau none of the people who use that
term even Marxist when people refer to
Marxist this or Marxian that vast
majority of those people have never read
Karl Marx they they just throw these
terms around as though they can fake it
till they make it as though if they
state these things with enough
confidence suddenly that will force
knowledge to just spring up in their
heads out of nothing
it's not just a Oh see we pick on aoc a
fair bit because she says a lot of
ignorant things it's in the media too
Katy tur on MSNBC which and NBC News I
think Donald Trump now refers to that as
MSDN see she was conducting an interview
and got the big NBC News draft backdrop
behind her and she's asking about these
problems of our electoral system and she
wants to know if gerrymandering the
rewriting of different congressional
districts is to blame for certain Senate
elections case you missed it majority
doesn't always rule in this country
forty-eight senators voted to remove the
president from office 52 voted to acquit
but the 48 actually represent 12 million
more vote
then the Senators who decided to keep
Donald Trump in the White House so what
is the what's the resolution to that is
is gerrymandering something that would
help improve the situation is how does
how does that sort of divide promote
consensus in the Senate or even in the
house well I mean they're the only
resolution gerrymanders not gonna do
anything in the Senate we're talking
about states right
I can't gerrymander States the only
solution is for Democrats to appeal to
voters in those states right oh that's
so awkward you know they were speaking
fast enough and the guy who was being
interviewed by her was courteous enough
to try to just move right past her
blatant error but Katie turn on MSNBC
was asking if the rewriting of
congressional districts right the
congressional districts refer to the
House of Representative if the
congressional districts would affect the
Senate race but the Senate has nothing
to do with the House of Representatives
the Senate you had a gazillion
congressmen right you got a zillion
people in the House of Representatives
you only have two senators per state so
unless you're gonna redraw the lines of
different states you're gonna make
Montana a little bit wider you're gonna
shrink New York in some way then
gerrymandering isn't going to affect
that at all but Katy tur is just
throwing words out buzzwords that you
hear in politics yeah you know 48
senators voted to to convict the
president in his impeachment trial and
sounds like gerrymandering yeah it
sounds like we're so in probably
Keynesian as well and so that's why the
president was not thrown out and the the
analyst was saying what are you talking
about that has gerrymandering has
nothing to do with a Senate trial and so
then Katy tur asks well how can we
address this problem why aren't there
more people in the Senate who hate Trump
and he says well if they want more
people in the Senate who hate Trump the
Democrats will have to appeal to the
voters it's pretty simple solution right
that's it that's a guy who knows what
gerrymandering is this lack of curiosity
this ignorance this this confidence and
saying things that simply aren't true it
has affected the presidential race it
really affects the left broadly and it
it doesn't
even to ignorance or to lack of
curiosity comes down to one vice in
particular that seems to afflict the
left we'll get to that in a second first
I need to tell you about my boxers and
how much I love them Tommy John Tommy
John has all the three F's fabric fit
and function what did you think I was
going to say Tommy John obsesses over
every little detail and stitch I have
never ever had better boxers than Tommy
John I love them as a result men's and
women's underwear from Tommy John have a
wonderful comfort guarantee they stay
put that waist bands are great they have
a range of fabrics that are truly
luxurious soft light moisture wicking
breathable no bunching no riding they're
just they're just luxury I you know I I
say this a lot when it comes to how I
sleep when it comes to clothing and
eyewear especially something as personal
as your boxers you just want the best
just get the best Tommy John you're not
gonna get any better Tommy John's so
confident if you don't love your first
pair you get a full refund with their
best pair you'll ever wear guarantee or
it's free right now go to Tommy John
dot-com slash Knowles kayo wles for 20%
off your first order that is Tommy John
dot-com slash Knowles Canada wles for
20% of you will not regret it Tommy John
dot-com / Knowles canna wles not just
AOC not just Katy tur you see this in
the presidential race with poor Joe
Biden Joe Biden is now making a bold new
proposal on the campaign trail to ban
guns that don't exist because we're
unwilling to have a rational policy says
you cannot have 20 30 40 50 clips in a
weapon a rational policy that says that
you can't have 20 40 50 clips in a
weapon I guess in Joe's defense it is a
rational policy to ban guns that are
completely imaginary right it would be
irrational to allow guns that are
completely imaginary and only exist in
Joe Biden's mind so I guess it
technically it's rational though I don't
know how rational it is just as a cam
paying that or to go out talking about
policies that don't have any bearing to
reality banning guns that have 20 40 50
clips per weapon Joe Biden doesn't know
what a clip is he doesn't know what a
magazine is very likely doesn't know
what a gun is a clip is not a magazine
people confuse this especially the
people who want to take your guns they
think that a clip is a magazine clip
feeds ammunition into a magazine
magazine feeds ammunition into the
chamber of a gun guns do not have 40 or
50 clips it's not not how guns work Joe
Biden could be forgiven perhaps this
ignorance he's obviously not a gun guy
doesn't know anything about guns
probably doesn't like guns very much he
likes having his armed security have a
lot of guns
I noticed he loves that but he clearly
doesn't like guns very much that's true
for virtually all of the Democratic
candidates with perhaps the exception of
Bernie Sanders but he's he's the one
writing the laws there's this strange
irony on the left and in politics where
the people writing the laws about guns
don't know anything about guns and
they're unwilling to listen to the
people who do know if you go to your
average perfectly common Walmart shopper
they will know more about guns than any
of these Democratic candidates for
president these days I don't know now
it's harder to buy a gun at Walmart but
for a long time you get the point you go
to the average Joe on the street outside
of New York LA San Francisco and depends
on what neighborhood you're in in New
York LA or San Francisco the person you
meet on the street will know much much
more technically they will just have
more knowledge of guns then Joe Biden
Budaj edge and Columbia char any of
these guys Elizabeth Warren that's
pretty weird that's a weird thing that
our so-called elites guys yeah I mean
that's certainly true of the media to
the people who run their mouths about
guns on MSNBC or CNN don't know anything
about guns the people who would have
themselves be our elites until
what to do and write our laws and tell
us what to think no significantly less
just as a matter of pure information
then your regular run-of-the-mill
American that's a strange situation to
be in
because your regular run-of-the-mill
American has a lot more humility than
those so-called elites Joe Biden took it
made it even a little bit weirder on the
campaign trail Joe Biden was asked a
question they didn't want to answer and
he referred to the young girl who asked
the question as a dog-faced lion pony
soldier
so you're arguably the candidate with
the greatest advantage in this race
you've been the vice president you
weren't burdened down by the impeachment
trials so in the participation so how do
you explain the performance in Iowa and
why should the voters believe that you
can win the national election it's a
good question number one I was a
Democratic caucus yeah Ben Dukakis no
you haven't you're a lying dog face pony
soldier you said you were but now you
got to be honest I'm gonna be honest
with you this is comment from Uncle Joe
made people wonder if he's doing okay if
he's all there in the head people are
saying that he's losing it that he's
becoming senile I know I don't think
that's exactly what's happening I don't
because his defense Joe Biden's defense
is that he's referring to an old movie
so what the people are saying is Joe
Biden is losing his mind and Joe Biden's
campaign defenses no no he's just really
really old and he's referring to an old
movie so what he's saying is it refers
to an old John Wayne movie trouble is
there's no evidence that that line comes
from a John Wayne movie at all he's used
the line before but there's no even even
the liberal outlet voxcom did some
research into this said we don't see any
evidence that that line came from a John
Wayne movie
it may have come from the 1952 movie by
Tyrone Power called pony soldier in
which a character says the pony soldier
speaks with a tongue of the snake that
rattles so it I guess it does kind of
allude to liars and people being
dishonest
even here even in this weird clip that's
going viral because people are saying
Biden's lost his mind or he's senile
this is evidence maybe you have a little
bit of those two things but really
evidence that Joe Biden is just saying
things that he doesn't know anything
about when his campaign comes out there
and says oh yeah it's from an old John
Wayne movie you don't worry even that's
not true even that is is not true and
they don't particularly care if it's
true big problem big problem for our
republic because an ignorant electorate
is not capable of self-government we
will get to why we'll get to what it
means first I've got to thank our
friends over at Rock Auto now those are
people who know what they're talking
about rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years which is pretty much the whole
history of the internet go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they've got everything engine control
modules brake parts tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet the only thing I really
know what that is on that list is carpet
whether it's for your classic or your
daily driver you can get everything you
need in a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door and actually it's
really really helpful for people like me
you don't know a lot about cars because
you go to a physical auto parts store
and they don't have any of your parts
they just order it online and charge you
a whole lot of money you go to
rockauto.com the catalog is so easy to
navigate you can find the parts that you
need it's just great even somebody like
me who doesn't know anything about cars
great selection reliably low prices go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and then right Noles
kenna wles in there how did you hear
about us box so that they know that we
sent rockauto.com an ignorant electorate
is not capable of self-government that's
the problem with these guys in our elite
institutions mostly on the left just
running their mouths ignorantly without
knowing anything Madison Riley wrote
quote a popular government without
popular information or the means of
acquiring it is but a prologue to a
farce or a tragedy that's how you could
describe the election of AOC the
election of AOC a farce or a tragedy or
perhaps both he goes on knowledge will
forever
ignorance and a people who mean to be
their own governor's must arm themselves
with the power that knowledge gives now
what's interesting is you might think
that this problem of ignorance spreading
throughout our republic would be
exacerbated by expanding the vote
because all those dumb people you know
in that flyover country they don't know
anything so if you expand the vote you
expand participation in the government
that's gonna make the ignorance problem
so much worse accept the ignorance
problem isn't among those our fellow
countrymen who come from the less
celebrated walks of life the ignorance
problem is from the people on TV and the
people who were sitting in Congress
that's where it's most visible there was
a study that came out in 2007 from the
Intercollegiate Studies Institute it was
a study of all the big fancy brand-name
colleges and universities in the country
and they they studied civic knowledge
politics history government they studied
it among incoming freshmen and
graduating seniors what they found is
the graduating seniors knew less about
their own country than the incoming
freshmen they actually became more
ignorant over their time in college they
actually unlearned whatever little they
already knew and they were so much more
confident about it because they walked
out of there with a degree from Harvard
or Princeton so they knew man I must
know everything what I say is the gospel
truth just because I say it that's an
that's a problem of ignorance it's a
problem of a lack of curiosity really
though at its root it's a problem of
pride because these elite institutions
whether it's a top school or a media
organization or Congress right or the
Senate most it most elite club in the
world
they those institutions flatter you
relentlessly that's what they do every
dinner every lunch every convocation you
go in and they tell you you're the
leaders of the world you're the best
oh you media people democracy dies in
darkness without you oh you're the fear
the future leaders you're the current
leaders of America and what happens is
you start to believe
your own press releases so you start to
believe yeah wow I really am I'm so
smart I'm so good
Wow I know so much more than everybody
and so every dumb thought every vague
sentiment feeling that pops into your
head you believe that that is true you
believe that that is knowledge you are
less aware of what you don't know these
elites are kind of like teenagers like
young teenagers who haven't yet realized
that their parents know something you
know you know teenagers before they
mature they're convinced that they know
everything so much better than their
parents their parents have never thought
or felt any of the really complicated
stuff that these teenagers have felt
right and then there's a a moment when
you mature and you realize oh my gosh my
parents actually know something my
parents actually have had the feelings
that I have had my parents have had
thoughts and questions that I have had
mm-hmm maybe I'm not the most special
little thing that's ever walked the
earth maybe I'm part of a grand
tradition of people who have come before
me and who will come after me that's
kind of how the elites are to the rest
of the people is the elites are always
shocked to find out that the rest of
their countrymen aren't complete idiots
but actually believe it or not the rest
of their countrymen might know something
that they don't know they might know a
little bit more about gerrymandering
than they do on on television they
frankly they might know about more about
economics than an economics major from a
good private college or university that
that is the problem that we're seeing
among our elites it's this pride if you
just got rid of the pride and you added
a little humility I think it would go a
long way to solving it yeah I've I
traveled throughout the country almost
all the time because I do these college
tours and so I'll go to really small
towns and I'm I remember the first time
it was right after that the Republican
tax bill was passed and but it's still
sort of being debated I got into an uber
somewhere in a small town in the middle
of the country and what do you do I work
in media ok we're kind of talking about
politics and this is a very nice
unassuming woman who was driving my uber
proceeded to explain to me how very
specific and technical provisions of the
tax bill would
affect her and her family I thought I
don't know anything about the technical
provisions of the tie no the overview of
the tax bill I've read part of the tax
bill I know that top line but she
actually possessed more technical
knowledge of the tax bill than I do and
it's not her job to read the tax bill
it's my job to read the tax bill yes I
thought wow that's pretty interesting
but she had such humility it made her so
much wiser than certainly anybody you
see on MSNBC or preaching to you from
the halls of Congress it's not
necessarily an ignorance problem I don't
mind how ignorant our friends on the
left are or even some people on the
right it's that they know so much that
isn't so a little little humility would
solve that now humility is different
than humiliation and Joe Biden is facing
the ladder on the campaign trail this is
a big day today today is the first in
the nation primary you had the first in
the nation caucuses at the Iowa caucus
two weeks ago a week or two ago I think
we're still counting the votes I don't
know that we're ever gonna get those
numbers not before the DNC completely
fries the books so far they're saying
Pete Budaj edge is one who knows if
that's true right now Joe Biden has to
make a good showing in New Hampshire
he's completely collapsing we will get
to the first-in-the-nation because
actually people have already voted
there's already a big winner in just one
tiny town in New Hampshire and it's a
town that I happen to have campaigned in
on behalf of another presidential
candidate we'll get to that in a second
we'll get to snoop doggy dogg said his
name i don't know well get to it but
first you've got a head on over to daley
wire.com you know we're talk to you
about our pal bill whittles podcast the
cold war podcast well it's now crack the
top 5 on Apple podcasts go to Daley
wire.com slash cold war and start
listening this is an extraordinarily
important story and it's very very well
done by Bill and everybody else who did
it daily wire.com slash cold war and you
know look I know it feels like we are at
least halfway through 2020 already truth
is we have barely gotten started the
elections heating up and you got to stay
up-to-date so we're gonna give you 20%
off all memberships it's my gift to you
you want to get on that right away this
promotion will be going away tomorrow
20% off all memberships when using the
code DB
you 2020 members get our articles
ad-free they get access to all of our
live broadcasts and show library they
get the full three hours of the bench
bureau show bonus content access to the
mailbag and now election insight op eds
from ben plus our new all-access tier
gets you into live online Q&A
discussions with me Ben drew Matt Walsh
and our sites writers and special guests
you ask we answer the leftist tiers
tumblr Phills right on up download The
Daily wire app which is also a member
exclusive you can get push notifications
straight to your phone you do not want
to put this off where you will miss out
that is promo code DW 2024 20% off join
today and stay informed on all things
2020 daily wire comm we'll be right back
with a lot more
Joe Biden absolutely collapsing he's in
freefall he was the Democratic
frontrunner he was the inevitable
nominee he was gonna do great in Iowa he
was gonna do great in New Hampshire the
whole argument for his candidacy is that
he's electable except nobody's electing
him yeah maybe he's a little out of
touch on the issues yeah maybe he can't
finish an English sentence because he's
lost some of his spark yeah maybe he's a
white male which is very unpopular in
the Democratic Party today especially
straight white males especially old
straight white males but look he's
electable right he'll do well against
Trump except can't win any elections
right now there's a pullout from WBZ
Boston Globe Suffolk University
it puts Joe in New Hampshire not in
first place not in second place not in
third place 4th place ooh that's bad so
he finished uno I mean who knows what
happened in Iowa but he finished toward
the bottom of the pack there he's very
likely to finish toward the bottom of
the pack in New Hampshire who knows how
he's gonna do in Nevada I don't know the
Nevada also is a caucus state nobody
knows if they're even gonna be able to
count the votes there are no Democrats
in Nevada saying they are unclear how
they are it is unclear how they're going
to report the votes back you could have
an Iowa part two then they move to South
Carolina South Carolina is Joe Biden's
firewall that's where he's gonna win the
election other candidates have tried
this before Rudy Giuliani famously in
2008 he was gonna skip the early states
and go straight to Florida but by the
time he got to Florida it was too late
he was already losing the race there is
a a study or a survey out from Emerson
College and Suffolk University putting
Joe Biden in fifth place in the
Democratic race the 5th place guy
doesn't win he doesn't barely wins the
state so the question now we have to ask
is is is Joe Biden Mitt Romney or Jeb
Bush that's the question of this race is
he the weak frontrunner that nobody
wants that nobody really wants to vote
for
except somehow he's just gonna outlast
everyone else and get the nomination and
then probably lose the general or is he
Jeb Bush the guy that the whole
establishment thought was going to be
the big one all the big-money donors
were behind going in and then he barely
wins a single vote which one is Mitt
Romney or Jeb Bush you know to Mitt
Romney's credit at least he won early
states in or got close to early states
in 2012 you know Iowa people thought
Mitt Romney won Iowa in 2012 he actually
slightly lost it when they finished
counting the votes so Rick Santorum
ended up winning it but Mitt Romney got
all the advantage of having won Iowa at
least he came in very close it was it's
pretty much a tie Joe Biden didn't get
anywhere near that Mitt Romney was
competing in all of these states Joe
Biden
not there and now there's a report that
some polls are showing Joe Biden losing
as much as half of his black support the
argument from electability for Joe Biden
in particular focus on the focus is on
his ability to win black voters the
Democratic candidate needs to win black
voters not just a simple majority of
them a vast majority of them needs to
win 85 90 percent of black voters to be
competitive in a general Joe Biden is
thus far the only candidate who's shown
that he can do that except he might not
be able to do that which is pretty
pretty sad
so Iowa took a full week the Iowa
Democratic Party is officially awarding
the most delegates to Buddha judge Pete
Lou de jedge mayor mayor cheat from
South Bend Indiana the whole thing
stinks to high heaven if I were Bernie
Sanders right now I would send a team of
lawyers to recanvass Iowa because I
think I don't want to deal in conspiracy
theories but it looks like there are
some high jinks here what what some
people are trying to say is that the
Iowa counting problem that was just a
random accident that happened to be
caused by a shady app produced by shadow
incorporated which just happened to take
some money from Pete Budaj edge which
just happens to be connected to the
Budaj edge campaign which just happens
to have have a connection to the old
Hillary Clinton campaign and the
Democratic establishment but look it's
all just a bunch of crazy coincidences
and it was pure incompetence just a
coding error
do you believe that that's a lot of
coincidences adding on top of that that
the Democratic Party stole the election
from Bernie Sanders in 2016 very hard
for me to believe him I think Bernie
Sanders would be a true disaster for the
country and possibly constitute a
fundamental break with our political
tradition if he ever got anywhere near
the ultimate levers of power however a
fair is fair and it looks like the guy
is being robbed it looks absolutely
crooked to me so what does all that mean
Biden collapsing Pete being named the
winner in Iowa people to judge who named
himself the winner in Iowa when zero
percent of the votes were in also looks
a little Shady
Bernie Sanders looks like he's being
cheated right now Bernie Sanders is
crushing at New Hampshire he's winning
in every poll Budaj edge if he wins New
Hampshire you're gonna see a bloody
knock-down drag-out where the Bernie
supporters are even more convinced that
the whole thing is rigged what does it
mean you've got an ugly ugly fight
coming up you could have a brokered
convention this is always what the
pundits are talking about if you have a
convention where there's no clear winner
going into the convention so instead of
just counting up all the votes from the
primaries and the caucuses you go in and
you go to smoke-filled back rooms and
you wheel and deal and you try to figure
out who the party's nominee is gonna be
we're in a position where that possibly
could happen because Bernie Sanders has
a lot of momentum in the party elites
really hate him and they've stolen it
from him before he doesn't want to be
fooled again they're not gonna let him
have it you could get to a place where
the DNC is going to be brokered and
bitter and absolutely hilarious and fun
to watch in terms of official votes we
have an official vote in from New
Hampshire we don't have the whole state
in that's gonna happen throughout the
rest of the day
but there is one town in New Hampshire
called Dixville notch that votes at
midnight on primary day and Dixville
notch only has about 12 registered
voters very small small number of voters
and so all the camera crews show up to
ask every voter when they leave the
polls who did you vote for to try to get
a sense of who's gonna win the state
doesn't always work doesn't predict it
necessarily but there was a real
surprise winner
here because do you know who won the
Democratic primary vote in Dixville
notch New Hampshire Mike Bloomberg a
candidate that we have not quite talked
about yet but who is surging in the
polls do you know who won the Republican
primary vote in New Hampshire this Trump
is gonna be the Republican nominee but
they still have these primaries and
caucuses
you know when the Republican primary
vote Mike Bloomberg now well it means he
got a couple of votes it doesn't mean he
won this huge number but you've get a
couple of votes in Dixville notch you
win the election Mike Bloomberg who has
variously been a Democrat and a
Republican he was elected as the
Republican mayor of New York cause it
was easier to win the Republican mayor
ship after Rudy Giuliani that way then
he became an independent now he's a
Democrat he won both primaries it's
pretty interesting because New Hampshire
is a live free or die New Hampshire is
pretty into keeping their constitutional
rights specially their gun rights and
yet the gun grabbing candidate won what
it shows you is Mike Bloomberg is in it
to win it he is he has already spent I
think like over 300 million dollars on
this campaign
he's just buying votes he bought off the
DNC made the maximum donation to the
Democratic Party that he could write
before he got in so that they would
change the rules of the debate which
means he's gonna qualify for the next
debates Mike Bloomberg is in it to win
it now he would have been a laughable
candidate when Joe Biden was a viable
candidate but if Joe Biden is really out
of this thing and increasingly looks
like it is all of a sudden a Bloomberg
campaign looks less crazy after that
last debate that nobody watched other
than me I watched it for you because I
care about you
Budda judge who was trying to get into
that moderate lane again he was down six
points then we have a new poll New
Hampshire at Suffolk University in
Boston Globe showed that post-debate
Sanders was up three points Budaj edged
down six points Amy Klobuchar up eight
points she had a very good performance
Biden up one point Warren down again two
points so it means that Bernie Sanders
is still the front-runner in this race
Joe Biden is
floating right he is still there but
Bloomberg is surging there's a new
national poll from Quinnipiac it's a
pretty good polling polling number
Bernie Sanders is 25 nationally Joe
Biden is 17 nationally third place is
Mike Bloomberg Mike Bloomberg the guy
got into the race very late former
Republican billionaire from New York you
think you're gonna be a billionaire from
New York with another billionaire from
New York increasingly the Democrats are
saying yes makes the whole situation
even more bizarre
now before Democrats get too excited
about having their savior in Michael
Bloomberg and never never thought they
would think that the campaign to attack
Bloomberg is just getting started one of
the big issues he's gonna have is on
racial issues because Mike Bloomberg
pushed a policy which was very effective
in New York called stop and frisk where
you would send cops into minority
neighborhoods and you know mostly
minority neighborhoods to reduce crime
but the left hated this because the left
hates reducing crime and they hated what
they perceived as a racial disparities
Mike Bloomberg owned it look this is a
billionaire from New York he doesn't
care he's got a lot of audio and video
out there of him saying things that is
not exactly politically correct here's
Bloomberg on the issue of racial
disparities yes that's true why'd you do
it the best we're all environment and
the way that we've done to other kids
thrown against the wall Christmas be
good and they started a whole I don't
like that I don't like it costly they
don't bring the gun based on now the
left when they find out about this when
they really start paying attention they
are gonna lose their minds over it and
some opportunistic conservatives are
going after my Klum Berg for this clip
certainly it was an artfully said if
you're trying to run for the Democratic
nomination but the actual policy that
he's defending stop and frisk was a
perfectly defensible policy Mike
Bloomberg was actually an okay mayor of
New York he wasn't great he was he did a
decent job of maintaining the prosperity
that Rudy Giuliani actually gave to New
York so he's fine he gets some credit he
did some dumb policies like banning big
mountain Dew's and not letting me smoke
in the park which was very frustrating
but all in all he was fine and he was
pretty good on crime this policy was
called stop and frisk you'd send the
cops in to neighborhoods that were
mostly minority now what Bloomberg
doesn't say in the audio what the
critics of stop and frisk don't say even
what some of the defenders don't tell
you is yes the cops were sent into
minority neighborhoods but the people
who were calling in these crimes were
also racial minorities and the cops who
were going to the neighborhoods were
also more likely than not racial
minorities its most New York cops or
racial minorities so this was not some
example of of the evil white supremacy
going into these poor downtrodden black
neighborhoods and and oppressing them it
was actually a case of the people
calling in the crimes mostly minorities
the victims of the crimes mostly
minorities the cops going in to solve
the crimes mostly minorities and also
the people perpetrating the crimes
mostly racial minorities that's not
going to matter in the Democratic
primary you're already seeing booed a
judge getting attacked for alleged
police brutality or racial disparity in
law enforcement and he's running in that
moderate Lane Bloomberg is gonna get
that times a million but I will say just
in Bloomberg's defense not that a whole
lot of far left-wing Democratic primary
voters are listening to this show but
for the few that are Bloomberg was much
better on this
for everybody racial minorities included
then the current mayor of New York you
know the current mayor of New York Bill
de Blasio the Bolshevik in in the
mayor's office has recently admitted
that his stupid prison reform bills are
damaging the safety of New York so de
Blasio passed something I guess it was
actually the New York State government
passed something but but with the
support of Democrats in the city passed
something called bail reform right
DeBlasio a big proponent of bail reform
and what bail reform does more or less
is lets criminals off the hook you get
arrested and then you just basically get
left off let off the hook and they go
out and commit more crimes almost
immediately and Bill DeBlasio even
admitted this he said quote we had for
six years steady decreases in crime
across the board there's not a whole lot
of other environmental things that have
changed recently it sort of stands out
like a sore thumb that this bail Reform
is the single biggest new thing in
question and we saw an extraordinary
jump the weak weak crime policies of
Bill DeBlasio making everybody less safe
and this is especially true in
particularly crime-ridden neighborhoods
and the particularly crime-ridden
neighborhoods in New York at least
happened to be mostly constituted of
racial minorities Mike Bloomberg
uniquely could run on this and defend it
if he wants to I'm gonna be pretty bold
campaign but that's gonna be a major
issue for him it might be disqualifying
even though now it looks like he's
surging speaking of racial issues before
we go I got to get to Snoop Doggy Dogg
and an interviewer on CBS so this
interview were on CBS get Gayle King is
was recently conducting an interview in
the wake of Kobe Bryant's death and she
brought up the question of Kobe Bryant's
rape allegations in the early 2000s here
is Gail's question it's been said that
his legacy is complicated because of
sexual assault charge which was
dismissed in 2003 2004 is it complicated
for you as a woman as a WNBA player it's
not complicated for me at all okay so
Gail asks this question
by the way she points out you know the
charge was dropped in 2003-2004 so it's
not like he was convicted for it
the accuser didn't want to testify so he
he is exonerated Kobe is exonerated but
there were these questions at the time
for some reason Snoop Doggy Dogg was
just really really offended that Gayle
King would ask this question and he went
after her in a vicious and actually
threatening way yeah okay out-of-pocket
for that way out of pocket what do you
gain from that I swear to God we the
worse we the worse we expect more from
you Gayle don't you hang out with Oprah
why are y'all attacking us we owe people
you ain't coming after Harvey Weinstein
asking them dumb questions I get sick of
y'all I want to call you what is it okay
if I call them one funky dog hit how
dare you try to touch my mother homeboys
reputation punk mother respect a family
and back off before we come get you
before we come get you yeah how dare you
tarnish the good reputation of my
friends as I threatened you threatened
to come kill you
or at least I don't know what he's
threatening he's certainly threatening
something there was a left-wing
journalist on Twitter yesh our ally he's
got a very big Twitter account he was
incensed by this video as most people
were but he blamed the problem on racism
and not Snoop Dog's racism actually
white racism he tweeted out quote seeing
very few people defending Gail I know
that if she were a white anchor she
would have much more support would she
really I I don't know about that yesh
our ally and Snoop Doggy dog both made
this racial Yashar in his comment snoop
in his video right he says come on why
are you coming after our people why are
you coming after us like that let's make
it making it racial the irony
to this race hustling is twofold one
plenty of people are defending Gail
Susan Rice the Obama's former foreign
affairs propagandist it was different
was defending Gayle King explicitly so
plenty people are defending Gail but too
very few people are going after Snoop
Dogg but really the issue here is what
Snoop Dogg said the issue is not Gayle
King it's what Snoop Dogg said right but
nobody's really going after him
including Yashar alley at least your
char is not going after him you sure did
this nine tweet thread about how awful
it is the no one's defending Gayle King
the way to defend Gayle King is to go
after Snoop Dogg he didn't do it
something tells me if it were Harry
Connick jr. who said this instead of
Snoop Doggy Dogg there would be a
different reaction to it or Michael
Buble or and Lisa they're sort of
singers right I mean you sure is
racializing this Snoop Dogg is
racializing this it's not a racial
question the question is is it okay to
ask a question about Kobe Bryant's past
innocent until proven guilty in this
country but surely journalists are
allowed to ask questions right but they
both racialize it where there's no
racial basis for it and and in the
assuras case he's raising the prospect
of white racism anti black racism when
there's no evidence of that either
I don't think Snoop Dogg is a white
supremacist this is another unfortunate
example of ignorance among our elites
not just yesh orally the whole left
doesn't david webb david webb
conservative radio host he was doing a
show one day and he had cnn's Arriva
martin come on in cnn's Arriva martin
accused him of having an invalid opinion
because of his white privilege and david
laughed at this those of you who know
david webb will also laugh at this
because david webb is very much a black
man he certainly doesn't have white
privilege now Arriva martin and this in
this case didn't accuse david webb of
this kind of racism of this white
privilege because it was a good argument
and she said even sincerely thought it
she just did it cuz she didn't care she
was ignorant of the
of white privilege and of who David Webb
is just ignorant and worse than that
confidently ignorant she knew so many
things that aren't so there is nothing
lazier than crying racism where none
exists because it requires no thought it
requires no insightiq requires
absolutely no communication and
increasingly that's that's what you see
from the left they use it all the time
so confident they're so insistent upon
it so proud and so completely untrue
how did our elites get so dumb now the
answer begins with pride and you don't
see that going away anytime soon all
right that's our show I'm where to get
through we'll have to do it tomorrow in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show see them the
Michael Noel's show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producers
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
assistant director Pavel madoski editor
and associate producer Dany D'Amico
audio mixer Robin Fenderson hair and
makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there